Hey, this is funny.
This is just a this is a light thing, OK?
This is not serious, but we've done a lot
of serious stuff today.
I posted a funny YouTube comment to my Instagram
the other day.
One of our callers called in and read it.
And it is even more incoherent when you hear
it read.
It's almost like an audience hatriot male.
Take a listen to this.
Hi, David.
You are a sweet you are a fake news.
Just like Donald Trump said.
You don't bring the news.
You bring whining.
Right.
Complaining things to complain.
Because if you're not understanding this,
you are not having a medical event right now.
It really doesn't make any sense.
I don't do what you want him good, want him
to do it right now, buying is doing what you
want him to do, so you're happy and criticizing
those people who are not sure.
That this is what needs to be done right?
And trust me, I looked at it several times
before posting it to my Instagram and it still
somehow made more sense then than it does
now, actually hearing it read out so that
that is really something else.
I love that we have a great bonus show for
you today.
We are going to be previewing our coverage
of the second impeachment trial of Donald
Trump, which starts tomorrow.
I don't even know what time yet.
I've been so busy today.
I'm guessing 10 a.m. maybe Eastern.
I don't know.
I'm just guessing.
But in any case, we'll figure out what time
it starts.
And we are going to have a very, very powerful
coverage for you.
And much more on today's bonus show.
Remember that to get instant access to the
bonus show, you need only sign up at join
Pakman dot com.
Very easy.
There is a coupon code.
The coupon code saves you a lot and the coupon
code is better.
Twenty one it could be all caps, all lower
case.
A mix of the two.
It is not case sensitive, but it must be spelled
correctly.
That's BTR 21.
No spaces whatsoever.
I would love to see you on today's bonus show.
Otherwise I will see you tomorrow.
New show.
And of course, of course, of course impeachment
coverage live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
And then after tomorrow we will be on vacation
for three months.
So I will see everybody then.
That's a joke.
By the way.
People get mad when we go on vacation.
We really don't take that much vacation, but
we're here all week.
All right.
I'll see everybody tomorrow or hopefully on
the bonus check.